this planet what's it called
trenzalore hey youtubers it's Charlie so
we finally gotten some more information
about the Christmas special including
some posters with some nice Easter eggs
even Peter Capaldi in the background but
so many of you have questions about
which version of the dr. Peter Capaldi
is going to be and even Steven Moffat
has said some things about the doctor
being the 14th incarnation so I thought
I'd do a video with the top five reasons
why the doctor can survive past his 12
regeneration limit that being considered
what Steven Moffat has actually said is
that what we're going to do is call
Peter Capaldi the 12th doctor but in
reality he is like the 14th doctor
because Steven Moffat is counting like
the meta-crisis and all those partial
regenerations if you didn't see and I
also started a Q&A show called ask
emergency it's just a show where I can
take your guys questions and answer them
directly in a video so my next one will
be a Doctor Who addition be sure to
subscribe to get it and leave your
questions after this video about the
regenerations or anything Doctor Who
related let's get started these are my
top five reasons why the doctor can
survive past his twelve regenerations
limit number five the Time Lords are
able to grant new regeneration cycles
during the five doctors they actually
offer the master a new regeneration
cycle even though they never delivered
they were able to offer that because of
the events of the day of the doctor
now that we know Gallifrey has survived
if the doctor ever does find it it's
possible for them to grant him a new
regeneration cycle in exchange for
saving Gallifrey
number four river songs early Christmas
present so during let's kill Hitler she
granted the doctor all four remaining
regenerations we saw her regenerate once
as a child and then twice during let's
kill Hitler that leaves eight
regenerations remaining if you don't
count the actual regeneration that
healed the doctor but then you have to
subtract one more after the time the
doctor healed river songs broken wrists
during the Angels Take Manhattan so that
would leave seven of rivers for
generations that the doctor has left
it's unclear as to whether regenerations
work like a faucet like you can turn it
on a little bit and just use a little
bit of regeneration energy or if it's
like a light switch like you flick it
once and that counts as one regeneration
number three advanced regeneration
theory so over classic whoo and modern
whoo there have been different theories
about how Time Lords regenerate and what
regeneration is this could actually be
an entire course on community so
somebody call Abed Steven Moffat could
use one of these alternate regeneration
theories as a loophole
the rule of 12 first there's long term
exposure to the untempered schism and
the time vortex we'll call that exposure
theory that's basically what gave River
Song her regenerations she was exposed
while she was a fetus inside of Amy Pond
high fives for sex on a TARDIS another
theory is the presence of
self-replicating biogenic molecules that
kind of rearrange and repair tissue
we'll call that the nanobots erie
another theory is that Rassilon altered
Timelord genetics to give them triple
helix DNA and that third helix is what
enables the regeneration will call that
genetic theory number two manipulation
of artron energy so think of this as
being like the midi-chlorians and Star
Wars only in name only it's like this
strange force that's connected to the
essence of life itself as well as time
travel
it's like background radiation during
the doctor's wife is actually what house
was feeding on when it tried to take
over the TARDIS so it's possible that
the doctor could find a way to
manipulate our Tron energy using the
TARDIS to kind of fill up his lifeforce
gas tank so to speak and my number one
theory we can also thank River Song for
this one - this is the escalation Theory
so during the force of the Dead she said
that the doctor has begun to gain powers
beyond that of a normal Time Lord that
could also mean that he's getting
regeneration powers beyond that of a
normal Time Lord the interesting thing
about this theory is that he really
wasn't aware of how he was changing on a
fundamental level until River Song told
him that so it's possible that he
totally still believes in this rule of
12 and thinks that after 12 he's
definitely going to die
so come Christmas he could actually
think that something really really
terrible is going to happen and just be
totally surprised whenever he becomes
Peter Capaldi so lots of theories some
with more evidence than others be sure
to post your best regeneration theory in
the comments below remember we're trying
to figure out how the doctor is going to
survive past 12 because the BBC isn't
going to stop making Doctor Who after
next year or after Peter Capaldi decides
to leave like I said earlier I'm doing
my doctor who asked emergency Q&A video
next week be sure to leave your comments
and I'll answer them a lot of you asked
for a longer video than the one I posted
last time so I'll try to pick at least
10 of your questions to answer in the
meantime check out my Doctor Who
Christmas trailer video by clicking here
and check out my latest Game of Thrones
video by clicking here thank you so much
for watching I'll see you guys tonight
high fives
you